passion person passion passion passion
passion pastor passion passion passion
everything I did I was following
something I really cared about something
I loved something I was passionate about
and I kept following that passion
whether it was cars whether it was
anthropology whether it was art
photography and eventually it led me to
my huge patch my real passion which was
making movies which combined all of
those things and I realized that had I
gone on to get my degree in anthropology
I would have probably made
anthropological movies in New Guinea or
someplace and eventually been on
National Geographic and you know the
History Channel and been then making
features and I had done Star Wars just
the same if I'd gone to the Art Center
and become an illustrator I would have
probably started doing animation and
doing animated films and making animated
things and in ultimately I would have
gone on and been right where I was so no
matter which route I took because I
cared about all of them they all went to
the same place had I done what my father
had wished me to do which is to go into
these office equipment business with him
which I knew like wasn't what can I do I
knew I hated that my life would have
been unpleasant and so I think it's very
important not to do what your peers
think you should do not do what your
parents think you should do or your
teachers but to do what you inside or
even your culture things but do what's
inside you
honestly that there's no difference the
way you win it the way that I win at the
game
I'm a go at business as hard as I want
at the game you know I study businesses
and I study people as much as I studied
people trying to figure out plays you
know so it's kind of something I told
the kids yesterday you know when you see
transition really start to happen when
you really want to transition to
something master there's no limits you
know that don't let the word I will put
limits on you you could do anything you
want to do but make sure if you have a
vision make sure the vision is written
you know make sure you have something to
actually chase and not just hoping and
wishing and all these different things
so if I tell guys this all the time
put your plan together and D work the
plan don't-don't-don't work somebody
else's plan right it's one thing by the
leek I love the leek but the league is
somebody else's brand right you have to
create your own brand yourself and your
brain is whatever you feel like doing
whatever you are is passionate about
chase it I don't know why but ever since
I was really young I thought I didn't
never have a problem making money
whatever I did so really it was a choice
of what was I gonna do for it and I just
had a passionate affair with music it
was a very amorous affair with music let
me tell you something man like for me it
doesn't matter what I do I could do all
of the Hollywood stuff and I could you
know and I do all that and everybody
knows about how fun of my life yeah all
of that but you know what there is
nothing on earth more like in fun and
crazy a while for me than just getting
on the records of rhyming and ham my
journal radio here might join a club
like like oh I don't even look I could
host of zillion Grammys I could you know
do TV shows and shoot bazookas and blow
cars and do all of that but none of that
another that gives me the adrenaline
rush and the thrill that you know music
gives me you know I'm saying and you
know so when you put your heart and soul
and your passion into something like you
know I can't walk away from that just
because because it never was business
for me it was always personal you know
I'm saying
music there's always personal to me and
I know I know that's almost win and an
era where it's all about being a
business man but for me music was always
personal like I just wanted to be the
best be hot and just have something hot
to hear my voice on a radio be heard and
just feeling you may have setbacks and
you may have failures but you're not
done you're not even getting started
not by a long shot and if you ever
forget that just look to history Thomas
Paine was a failed corset maker a failed
teacher and a failed tax collector
before he made his mark on history with
a low book called common sense that
helped ignite a revolution
Julia Child didn't publish her first
cookbook until she was almost 50 Colonel
Sanders didn't open up his first
Kentucky Fried Chicken til he was in the
sixties Winston Churchill was dismissed
as little more than a has-been who
enjoyed scotch a little bit too much
before he took over as prime minister
and saw Great Britain through its finest
hour
no one thought a former football player
stocking shelves at the local
supermarket would return to the game he
loved become a Super Bowl MVP and then
come here to Arizona and leave your
Cardinals to their first Super Bowl your
body of work is never done
each of them at one point in their life
didn't have any title or much status to
speak of but they had passion a
commitment to following that passion
wherever it would lead and a working
hard every step along the way and I mean
what does it mean to survive as a
mission as a musician what does it take
you know we make money we make a living
and it's a great living now after you
know we were signed in 1998 so we
invested in ourselves time energy
passion blood sweat tears as well as
other things and you know it took a long
time and now we have an incredible
touring life so the touring is really
where most artists pay the rent you know
there's there's an accepted wisdom that
artists really don't think so much about
making a living from selling albums but
for me
it's never been about even making a
living it's been about passion it's
about about making something from
nothing it's been about sharing things
with other people it's been about
creativity that it's been about dreams
and that's what it should always be
about because no one feels like they're
good enough yeah like no one does like
everybody we all I mean like I hauled it
20 years yeah we were all like around
that age where it was
like like jobs weren't there after they
came and people were just kind of like
oh that's what I feel like I'm being
lied to because it's just like everybody
kind of became a freelance photographer
free life today everybody became a
freelance that thing and then you
realize like oh man no one's really
happy like play no one really no one's
really happy because we're not obtaining
those goals that everybody told which
ones have kids and do like all these
things yeah we're supposed to and no
one's really happy because like they
realize like all those things are kind
of not what make you happy but that's
what our parents did to like have
purpose they were like at and now we
have all that stuff and like the thing
we're supposed to do is really be
helping each other but we've been
brought up in this kind of like well I'm
supposed to be like the the top-ranking
manager at this thing by this point
after and it's not and it's not real
this is not real it's not necessary
everybody should be just following their
passion because they're gonna be good at
that and most but like people are too
worried about you know you know their
jobs because people gotta eat it's that
it's not sad but it's just like it's
true like people gotta eat and I feel
bad like I I don't want to be the guy on
camera feeling you should be following
your dreams and then people like I have
five kids you know you know I can't do
that but I I think it's true like people
are scared and vulnerable it's it is
it's dangerous to do that but I don't
think we're gonna grow if we don't
follow what you're passionate about what
you love you if it's not work if you
love what you're doing okay
most people when I say they're living
quiet lies the desperation is because
they're involved in a business or end or
a job that they don't enjoy they don't
they're not passionate about okay so if
you found something that you're
passionate about then it doesn't matter
if you work three hours a day or 13
hours a day that's where you start and
most people aren't there most people
have to find that coming from modeling
where does the business background come
from I mean there are other models who
have tried to turn something else
but you've developed a full business did
that just come along the way I think
most of it it was a natural progression
it wasn't something I really thought
about it and really
but everything else had to be everything
of it has to be authentic
so the cosmetics was a natural given
because I could never find cosmetics for
myself all the years of models so there
was a natural progression because not
only I was looking for for one but all
women women of skin of color were asking
me the same thing so a man cosmetics
launching it was really a natural the
other stuff was really passion the man
home is my passion I love love interior
decorating so that was really truly just
passion and the HSN global chic because
it isn't came to me and I created a
small collection of of accessories and
then it just became more and more and
now it's like the number-two fashion
brand at HSN in my career I've been
fortunate to know and work with many of
this country's top CEOs and business
leaders I'm always struck by a certain
passion that defines them while they may
be wealthy and powerful their passion
goes beyond money and power I won't
stand here and tell you that those are
bad things they're pretty good but only
if you have a larger purpose in mind if
you don't have passion for your work or
the drive to make a better life for your
kids in your own then you won't have
what it takes to keep you going thank
you guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I'd love to know which of the
clips you liked the best
and why and also how do you find and
follow your passion and what
difficulties are you having right now
leave it in the comments below I'm gonna
join in the discussion thank you guys so
much for watching continue to believe
and I'll see you soon